today's topic Hogwarts Lego so if you
don't know Hogwarts Legacy is the newest
addition to the Harry Potter franchise
and it is expected to be one of the
biggest video game launches of the year
as well as one of the most controversial
ones because there are scores and scores
of people on social media saying that if
you buy this game you are transphobic go
not to put everyone into the most
extreme basket there are others pushing
the more mild take that it's simply
unethical to buy the game because it
supports JK Rowling so some of the
things we've seen in addition to viral
Twitter and Tick Tock post saying you
know you're a trans book if you buy this
we all saw many streamers boycotting
with twitch is hosting an ad campaign
for the game it is because even though
the game's producer said that Rowling
had no input in the game and actually
people have noticed that there is a
trans person in the game there is an
expectation that she's going to accept
royalty payments with trans streamer
nicotine tweeting I call on every
streamer to join me in taking a stance
against bigotry hatred and those who
support such views but since then a
number of streamers have gotten early
access to the game and twitch has become
a [__] fire store like there's this
one clip that's gone absolutely viral of
uh girlfriend reviews you see them
getting bombarded by hate comments or
playing Hogwarts Legacy that the
girlfriend leaves the room in tears and
every time I look at chat it's just the
conversation is just like maybe we can
do like bothering them
like a like a little break or something
yeah I'm gonna say this bro I'm gonna
say this
if I'm playing that game and you in my
comment sections you're like oh you are
Turf I'm like you could suck on the turf
nuts
[__] you and all you people out there
going to cry because you're getting some
angry comments or some losers on Twitter
talking about your retreat [__] them too
[__] them all
lose their ass time I can't play a game
because it supports so
95 the [__] you wear right now is going
to support somebody that's unethical
your goddamn cell phone is going to
support unethical Behavior doesn't
matter if it's iPhone or whatever if
there's a leaf lithium battery in that
[__] you support child labor if you're
wearing Nike's child labor if any of
your clothes is made in Bangladesh child
labor which probably is stop
that's exactly my point but go ahead if
you want to make the case that you're
upset with potential money going to some
person involved in the Creations I could
understand but think about how many
other people you're going to be harming
through the process how many people put
their Blood Sweat and Tears into this
video game which by all accounts is an
exceptionally well done game what how
who cares how you feel about Harry
Potter the game itself is amazing you're
gonna [__] over all these developers all
these designers everybody worked on the
game the testers the Publishers
everybody
they should have worked on a better game
Abba
I'm not even gonna get into the fact
that JK roll is or is it I don't even
care I'm just thinking about like have
you guys thought this [__] through no of
course of course not people are crying
because they get in comments she was
like man some of y'all are brittle yeah
I believe that that's a real generation
that we have right now uh people are
talking about oh my God oh my God oh my
God internet is bad yeah it's bad it's
Internet it's bad people when they
whenever they can hide be on a screen or
whatever it's gonna be [__] up they're
gonna be bad
I'll say this I don't even think this
generation is soft I think human beings
are generally for the most part not
equipped to handle a lot of this kind of
criticism online I think you're right I
think even if this [__] existed 30 years
ago uh yeah yeah and people are getting
this much hey they would probably feel a
lot of pressure the day people want to
be socially accepted by folks and so
some people may not have the mental
fortitude to be online content creators
to be honest yeah and that notably
happening on a stream where they were
actually raising money for the Trevor
Project also someone even created a
website where you can see all the
streamers who played the game so you can
unfollow or Target them something to
call this a literal Witch Hunt pun
intended it was my big names in the
space weighing in on this like asthm and
gold who stated his position in Stark
terms I don't give a [__]
yeah if the game's fun to play I'm gonna
play the game man of course the homeless
guy says this bro like he has nothing
they're loose he's homeless
stupid
it's one of the richest creators I'm not
stupid I don't know this dude he got a
whole setup I don't know this dude like
you're every time you have to understand
every talk every time you talk about
streamer and [__] yeah maybe he's a
homeless streamer maybe that's a [__] I
don't know to do that's some nerd [__]
to me you understand I don't know that
world yo low-key low-key I wouldn't mind
watching a homeless streamer you know
what I mean looky like if they were
doing IRL streams being like all right
today you gotta get some crack look I'd
watch that you know what I mean
wouldn't that be [__] entertaining
forget an ad break how about some crack
breaks
if people get mad about something on
Twitter you just ignore it for like
three days and it goes away and pointing
to exploit date of Labor practices in
the third world and accusing the
boycotters of hypocrisy like is this
really worse like how are you boycotting
Harry Potter but you're not boycotting
Apple yo as one gold just because you're
homeless doesn't mean you get to steal
her takes
[__] is you talking about bruh
the worst thing I'm getting so sick of
white creators just taking from [__]
like this oh Jesus Christ [__]
said that [__] before we we're walking
yeah yeah we're watching him yeah yeah
all you people support this dude y'all
too
Hassan biker who's a massive streamer
speaking on us the only reason why I'm
not playing this game and I know a bunch
of other people are not playing this
game is because we know that it's not
worth it to get bullied endlessly and
called transphobic endlessly in it when
we have massive uh queer communities and
audiences that's it wait hold up
you're not playing the game because you
don't want to get called transphobic
endlessly now you know how we felt when
you kept doing that to us transphobic
transphobic transphobic transphobic
transphobic transphobic transphobia
transphobic transphobes transphobic
transphobic transphobic transphobic
transphobic
this is you Abby you gotta own it a
little bit you talk about is unfair
brother you're part of that culture yeah
you said that you're part of the problem
you said that you're the one who throws
them labels out very Loosely uh it's
because you're transphobic uh
transphobia uh trans that's you and I
don't wish it on you I don't think it's
fair that these people are doing that
but I'm not gonna lie you kind of [__]
mate when the [__] monster you
created is coming for you and now you
want to get out the way let it eat
everybody else yeah no that's your
problem you help create that you said
that to an actual trans person listen
you're just trans you don't understand
that I'm just saying I'm just saying
it's kind of crazy right now that
[__] like and I want people to
have a more positive approach to dealing
with issues transphobes transphobes
transphobic transphobic transphobic
transformable transphobic you are just a
trans person sorry you don't know what
the [__] you're talking about let me
just say this
you still [__] make for not playing the
[__] game because you're afraid of
some some bullying he's what [__] mate
okay but I'll say this
oh yes yes Liz I'm sorry you're a
grown-ass man who can't play a game
because you're worried about some
Twitter words like bro stop it I don't
want to be called transformed because
actually [__] you oh you Turf yay
whatever team Turf [__] let's go I
don't care
bro people have called me that for so
long at this point I don't it doesn't
mean anything we should we should come
out with merch
that's what I started to do yeah just
take everything they say just turn it to
March yeah that's what I did team Turf
whatever whatever that's what I did I
don't care like I'm probably not gonna
make merch team Turf but yeah
everybody's keep calling us apple and
Peach I made some apple and Peach merch
that's going to be uh available soon we
like apples we like peaches eat them
whatever by the merch too I don't care
you like pizza people have used the word
transphobic for everything that it
doesn't mean anything so yeah I am
transphobic whatever it makes you feel
good yeah I'm racist I'm I'm xenophobic
uh agoraphobic whatever the phobic I am
yeah I am so what suck my I just
realized something I did to a trans
person is a wild thing to say
not really no no because you can return
the favor
[Laughter]
okay that's actually transformed but
then we talk about that everybody
everybody knows everybody knows how much
left is love the chirp on the internet
they got no power all they do is chirp
chirp chirp and that's precisely why so
many people that would otherwise like
play it maybe even raise money for uh
you know Charities or whatever I got
yelled at uh endlessly and relentlessly
uh on my alt account like they were
making it seem like I was already
transphobic for even thinking about this
and now look at that what he's
referencing there is that earlier he
tweeted I was planning on playing
Hogwarts Legacy and inviting every
streamer friend who plans on playing it
to a healthy competition to do a
fundraiser for Trans Charities of our
choosing it is also something I've seen
other creators like the act man mention
in the past or the general idea being if
the game itself is not transphobic and
your issue is with JK Rowling why don't
you negate that benefit by donating to
trans Charities but whatever your
opinion of this situation is there's one
thing that is undeniable that is that
this game may actually be one of the
most successful launches of the year
it's already topping bestseller list or
both PC and console people are viewing
it on Twitch like crazy don't you love
it when transphobia thrives it's just so
basic
isn't it just delicious I mean let me
just say put another dub up there for
team Turf I mean we're starting off this
league three points ahead of everybody
else teams are up in the building
Hogwarts Legacy what is it transphobia
and here's the thing the sales for this
have probably been supercharged because
of this controversy like half the [__] I
know about this game has been force-fed
to me because social media platforms
love that algorithm engagement
engagement engagement especially because
the only people that are going to be
hurt in this situation or content
creators how many times have we seen
backlash on social media about a thing
and then it's just not in any way affect
how many people actually played the
thing especially because everything
about this ends up promoting the game
even in action or the absence of it
becomes a news story for example several
gaming Outlets have declined to review
the game and IGN that did tackle it
added this caveat where it said quote
whether it's ethical to play as a
separate but still very important
question you know what Loki I'll say
this I feel bad for a lot of trans folks
a lot of them don't care about this no
most of them don't give a [__] about
this the one that do it very loud yeah
it's not even them just like it is with
a lot of black issues it's a bunch of
white leftist streamers who feel like
they want to get online with their blue
hair we talk about like I can't get a
job
I'm just sick shut up okay content
creators got to grow some [__] balls
okay stop being such goddamn [__]
grab your dick grab your grab your grab
your boom boom grab whatever you got if
you got both use them if you switched it
up use them too okay and and get to work
get to work what the [__] whatever you
added remove subtracted inverted
outverted I don't care use it anything
you want to say about Harry Potter big
fan no not a big fan
you don't think it's kind of gay
that they get on broomsticks and try to
chase flying balls
[Laughter]
you know nobody know what it is
no I'm not gonna lie Jinky rolling into
the fire emcee name
yes I hate it yo yo JK Rowling cause
[__] we stay rolling on the enemies the
turfs stuff